Michael's with us in Chicago a Michael
how are you I'm well I'm well my friend
um I can ask you a question and it could
be a difficult or tricky question
possibly if you can if you can give me a
yes or no answer I'll try alright is
investing a gamble is investing gambling
no is it a gamble well a gamble would be
is there risk involved at all is getting
in your car and driving to work a gamble
yes you might get creamed
at the stoplight but is it gambling no
it is not so a gamble is a measure of
risk gambling to do the wordsmithing
here is different than investing there
is a difference between investing and
gambling gambling is you're putting
money out and there is no benefit there
is no financial transaction occurring at
the blackjack table except they're
either gonna win your money which is
most of the time or you're gonna lose it
which is most of the time or you're
gonna win which is very seldom I mean
but there's no you know when those cards
are dealt at the blackjack table that's
gambling there is no financial
background to whether you get an ace of
spades or not okay
but when you're putting money into say
for instance a mutual fund there's a
financial transaction that's going on
with those companies that are involved
that you can look at okay they own Home
Depot well Home Depot is making a profit
and that profit is why their stock is
there and we're looking at the track
record of their profitability and that's
where their stock price comes from and
that's part of my mutual fund purchase
or when you buy a home you're not
gambling that you're investing although
there's not a guarantee you aren't but
there's a financial transaction that
occurs there in that homes have and then
have a value they can create an income
where you to rent them and other homes
on the neighborhood are selling for a
certain amount and so that's the
difference in investing in gambling
there's actually financial math
Maddox involved under and money being
made and transferred under an investment
under a gamble it's just the court toss
of a coin and that's a risk a pure risk
and it's just a guess and so investing
is not gambling from a spiritual or from
a mathematical standpoint but it is a
gamble in that a gamble means there's
risk involved just as there is you're
getting in your car and driving it to
work is that logical to you that is I do
understand what you know the point you
are making there I
I'm just not can't I've tried it twice I
put some money couple a couple times at
different times what did you put it in
fidelity probably close to ten years ago
I put in five thousand dollars and I
don't manage it what is it turned into
it has lost inators down to under two
thousand over ten years the last ten
years yes well you pick one of the
world's worst mutual funds but Ellie's
got a lot of funds that didn't do that
are you sure you got your numbers right
I don't think that's right Dave I mean
they may have a fund that sucks that bad
but it's a rarity now that's not
gambling that's investing poorly this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show